if you thought that the idol chatter
about
aku like in myanmar and trump posting to
his blog
about audits were happening in a vacuum
you were very much wrong the new york
times
maggie haberman is now reporting that
donald trump is telling people privately
he will be reinstated as president of
the united states by august of this year
this is actually something that more and
more q anon people are attaching to now
now the context here
is that on sunday night trump's former
national security adviser
michael flynn remember the guy who was
indicted and convicted and then pardoned
by trump
he said to an audience that there should
be a
coup here like the one that took place
in myanmar
that's outrageous enough but this
appears to be part of
i hesitate to call it a political
movement but it's part of
something that trump is again ginning up
which again might lead to real violence
so here's the latest from the new york
times's maggie haberman who tweeted
yesterday that quote
trump has been telling a number of
people he's in contact with that he
expects
he will get reinstated by august no that
isn't how it works but simply sharing
the information
now the concept of reinstated is
hilarious when
you know the process for presidents
becoming president is being
elected reinstated is not a term that
applies to the presidency it's
you're elected and then you're
inaugurated and then you serve who would
reinstate him
is the idea of the supreme court how
would that work it doesn't make any
sense
maggie haberman goes on to say quote it
isn't happening in a vacuum
it is happening as he faced the
possibility of an indictment from the
manhattan district attorney
and then lastly adding that quote he is
not putting out statements about the
audits and states just for the sake of
it
he's been laser focused on them
according to several people who've
spoken with him
as well as washington post reporting a
few weeks ago
now whether donald trump thinks he'll be
back by coup
or by some other means isn't clear
but the entire myanmar-style coup thing
to take joe biden out of the white house
has been floating around queuing on
circles for months
and here's an interview done by cnn with
with such people
i guess we would call them who have the
same idea biden is just
he's like a puppet president uh the
military is in charge it's going to be
like myanmar what's happening in myanmar
the military is doing their own
investigation and at the right time
they're going to be restoring the
republic with trump as
president different countries the
government took over and they're
rejoining the election correct
that could possibly happen here possibly
would you like to see it happen
absolutely like to see it really yes you
know why
because the election was stolen from us
i would take any bet
that this is the first time most of
these people have even heard of myanmar
i mean seriously and and certainly the
first time they've ever pretended to
care about it
so of course none of it will happen but
in the process of not happening
if it just gets enough oxygen it might
inspire more violence
it's easy to laugh and to say ignore
this crap
forget it or whatever but these are
dangerous delusions they
are delusions but after the january 6
trump riots we can't say they are merely
delusions they are
dangerously deluded now some are already
saying
put two and two together david michael
flynn says there should be a coup
trump is thinking about august trump is
planning a violent coup
we can't say that yet i wouldn't put it
past trump to try it
and it wouldn't work but we really
shouldn't say that he is planning a
violent coup because we don't know that
and that would be irresponsible
would he be morally opposed to it no
probably not
um are we to expect new arbitrary
announcements about august september
what up for the next few years probably
this helps with fundraising i'm sure
many of them
probably don't realize it's never going
to happen and once august comes and goes
it'll be january and then it'll be
listen the way to take this back
is actually to vote republicans in
in november of 2022 so that they take
control back of congress then we can
impeach
biden and replace him with donald trump
it'll just keep going and going and
going it's the never-ending grift
but this is my last thought and this is
important
if this is true that donald trump is
seriously telling people i'll be
reinstated as president by august
it's a grift but it's not just a grift
it's working to grift money from people
but if trump really believes it himself
that's scarier than trump merely being a
con man he is a con man
but then he also seems as deluded
himself
as are many of his followers and to me
that's even scarier
let me know what you think let me know
what percentage
of trump's followers really believe
trump could be reinstated by august and
how many understand that that's just
never ever ever going to happen we'll
take a quick break
and be right back after this i'm really
excited that
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
i sleep on a helix mattress at home i
absolutely love it and that's why i
reached out to them
about sponsoring the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video